yeah look at that you can see the
butterflies flitting about every blade
of grass the flowers they're even just
like that the texture is on all of the
decaying architecture there it all just
looks so so good welcome back to
PlayStation underground what a privilege
it is to be sitting here at Blue Point
Games in Austin Texas I'm joined by
Marko thrush the president of the
company hi wait and Peter Dalton
technical director on Shadow of the
Colossus for ps4 hello
hey thanks for being here guys well
rather thank you for letting us be here
this is a quite a change for PlayStation
underground to be recording on location
here super excited to be seeing Shadow
of the Colossus you can see already that
this game just looks absolutely stunning
such an upgrade from the ps2 version and
the more recent ps3 version Marko I'd
like to start by talking to you just
about the project and kind of how far
the company has come what's it like now
working on this massive overhaul this
this new version rebuilt from the ground
up for ps4 it's a great opportunity
we're finally over the different
projects we've done over the years
finally grown to the point where we can
finally take a project of this kind of
scope on and and actually do it justice
so it's it's it's really great cool and
I should mention that we have our pal
Russell here sitting on the floor next
to us he can't he can't be seen on the
camera but sorry Randall yeah Randall is
here he's playing the game for us he's
piloting there you can always find just
don't call me Shirley yeah don't call
you Shirley
look I've had one day to get everybody's
name straight I'm working on it Randall
is here and he's driving he is the
producer on the project and I got that
right yeah okay great you know so yeah
and we we have some great chats earlier
he's going to carry us forward to
victory with no deaths no stumbles
whatsoever I'm gonna make this game look
absolutely perfect well Peter I'd like
to talk a little bit about the technical
side and I think that you're a good
person to talk about that this game is
quite and quite an upgrade from the
general ps2 version of Shadow of the
Colossus how do we get from there to
here you know I think it's been a lot of
fun and when we had the opportunity to
remaster the original for the ps3 it was
much more of just bringing up textures
and resolutions on a few things we've
gone to the point now where we are
basically remaking every single asset in
the game you look at the geometry and
the detail that we've added to the
environments and the atmosphere it's a
completely reinvigorated the original
remaster of the game from character
animations to the physics to the water
simulations to the particle systems yeah
look at that you can see the butterflies
flitting about every blade of grass the
flowers they're even just like that the
texture is on all of the decaying
architecture there it all just looks so
so good see the waterfalls up there and
this looks incredible so I think we're
headed off to find find one of the
colossi which one are we headed to right
now we're headed to Colossus eight
losses eight so where were always was
this about halfway through the game or
exactly yep cool i shamefully admit that
I didn't I didn't make it this far when
I played the game back on ps2 so I'm
really looking forward to being able to
experience this for myself and finally
resolve one of my greatest gaming shames
of never having finished out of the
Colossus well we're glad to give you
that opportunity so we see we see wander
climbing these pillars here I remember
hearing that the controls have been
updated here Marco can you tell us a
little bit about that yeah so we offer
multiple control schemes we offer the
original control scheme for the original
player and that mattress the ps2 and ps3
version and we have a new one which we
consider to be better suited to mute new
players that have never played any of
the original games before it's more
traditional button mappings
in addition to that all of the moats
also received additional improvements to
behavior of mounting aggro I mean there
are so many small details you could
enlist I mean Peter like what what do
you think are some of the most obvious
ones though aiming when you shine the
sword on your light making sure camera
orientation and such are taken into
consideration just minor touches and
tweaks that the original didn't possess
but it just makes the game feel a little
more fluid as a player there's a lot of
an animation improvements done to the
player package to to get rid of pops and
harsh transitions between animation and
oceans yeah how tempting was it to go in
and further simplify the controls or add
more modern niceties like being able to
move around while the bow so any of the
changes you pretty much just listed will
be changes that would dramatically
affect the way the game played our
intent was never to change the way the
game played we didn't want to affect the
difficulty of the game ideas such as
removing a gripmeter or allowing you to
aim while a move while aiming the bow to
us would have been like those were
actually items specifically we discussed
but there were items that we discounted
because they would just change the way
you played the game too much and we
didn't want to - to effect original
players of the game - that kind of
degree we wanted to maintain the
original intent of the day make a great
example is if you look at modern games
these days you can run and climb and
grab onto walls and parkour with little
thought with just directional input on
the on the joystick one of the key
aspects of this game is actually like
holding r2 in order to hold and grip and
that sense of tension that that brings
and to simplify and remove that would
really lose an important essence of the
original game yeah absolutely I mean
I'm sure that there are some out there
who would call you
blasphemers for changing the game at all
all right where do you draw the line
it's pretty difficult there's no way you
can attempt a project of this scope and
not make somebody unhappy sure we're
trying to do our best to minimize the
people we do make unhappy by providing
choices like for example the classic
mode for the controls I feel like this
is going to make a lot of people very
happy yes I hope so I hope so or a lot
of people seem to be happy about it
already from from what we've seen the
game was only just revealed III I think
it was right it wasn't be through and
we're already I mean we're already so so
close to seeing the final product here
you got this you got this
yeah oh man I'm getting caught up in
this Colossus battle I love the way that
the symbols
Colossus light wander when he's on top
of it yeah it's it's little touches I
mean like the glowing likes themselves
they light up the environment too yeah
yeah so that's the kind of stuff that
you don't really like until you actually
bring the game up on a ps4 and improve
the quality of the graphics a lot of
those kind of details are things that
just naturally are obvious that they're
lacking you play the game and it's like
man it looks really weird that there's
this bright glowing thing but there's no
light coming from it yeah yeah so
there's a lot of small touches that were
things we didn't actually originally
even think about that
you have to actually get to the point of
the game looking to this level to be
able to even realize the things that
were missing
yeah well I think that that was even the
revealed trailer at e3 that was maybe
the most goosebump inducing moment was
that final shot of the panning camera
around with him lit by the symbol and
then that final stab and then the cut to
black Atlantic getting goosebumps just
thinking about it so good getting tingly
tell me a little bit more about some of
the other technical improvements let's
talk about the ps4 Pro features we're
actually playing this on ps4 pro right
now we're seeing this game running at a
4k resolution this is a cinematic movie
this is our cinematic mode that we offer
we get a lot of evaluations looking at
different 4k kit for K rendering
techniques and we found that given the
atmosphere of this game and the softness
that the game is trying to bring in the
mood we implemented a 440 P temporal
alias 1440 I'm sorry all over the place
hey temporal aliasing can fill a lessee
of sampling and so that gives it much
nicer feel Yoga it really helps with the
image quality at the end well aliasing I
feel like I heard that
[Applause]
we were hearing about Ratchet and Clank
they used something similar yeah our our
technique for for 4k rendering is very
similar to the retro and Clank method
yeah and it's yeah it's a temporal super
sampling is essentially what it is in
this case well it looks absolutely
stunning there's also a performance mode
what does that entail so performance
mode allows us to hit a target at 60 FPS
mode it allows you to have greater you
know if it just feels a little bit
smoother for the gaming purists that can
appreciate an increased frame rate can
appreciate the extra motion fidelity and
stuff that you get when you're battling
the colossi it's so just it's just a
little extra punch to put the cherry on
so does it feel weird playing this game
at a higher framerate or there's a
because I feel like this was you know so
many people remember this game in its
original form and obviously there's the
you know cinematic mode which is kind of
the you know most beautiful way to me I
think it depends on on the person you
ask which is exactly the reason why we
actually give you the option to play
either at the original framerate
targeting 30 or the new framerate
at the higher performance mode targeting
60 because some people will always
prefer running at 30fps sure if you give
them 60 FPS they will be unhappy then
there's other people you only give them
30 and that 160 we give them the best of
both worlds like we have other options
in the game for the exact same reason
being able to adjust the intensity of
motion blur some people like motion blur
some people don't so we always try to
give people the choice cool so how much
bigger of a project is this then when
you remaster the game for ps3
on lots of thinking happening here it's
a completely different exponential scale
yeah it's yeah the original project was
done with two QA on internal and our end
we had majority of the team was
programmers and we had one artist
touching up some textures and this is on
this team completely rebuild it's
completely rebuilt from scratch every
single acid high risk gulps created
normal Maps baked down PBR textures
created
yeah so how existing animations updated
brand-new Waterson brand-new particle
systems created for every single
particle effect new particle systems at
it yeah but obviously you want it to
evoke the same feeling of the original
game you don't want it to feel different
you want it to feel the same but but
better like it's such a weird like fine
line you guys have to walk you want to
take the original game and pretend that
this team existed now making this game
for the ps4 like what would they have
done yeah yeah I think at the same time
when people play the original that you
have this installer and you have these
memories and your mind is filled in the
gaps when you look at a ps2 gaming
you're playing it just because they've
got a flat plane you assume that well
this is where the grass area is here's
the hillside and your mind sort of
pieces it together with the level of
fidelity of graphics that we're hitting
today you can't just assume the player
will make it up or piece in the gaps by
themselves and now it's our ability to
go through and actually expose that and
actually bring it to life so now we're
wandering around the plains here so we
did see that that was the 8th Colossus
that we wrapped up there I think that
was yeah nice work on that Randall thank
you
so yeah that is a Shadow of the Colossus
on ps4 running on a ps4 Pro and a
beautiful new cinematic mode Marco
Randall Peter thank you guys so much for
joining us is there anything else that
you wanted to say to the fans leading up
to the launch of shadow with Colossus
[Music]
this week we put into this game we're a
huge fans with the camera ourselves cool
well thank you guys so much I'm so
excited to play this for myself thank
you for tuning in to PlayStation
underground and we'll see you next time
[Music]